hey guys it's Tuesday I'm Dan that's
Jess and this is GameSpot news it's been
a while since I've been able to talk
about Rainbow six siege a seriously
great game that's only gotten better
with time and today more changes are
coming with the tear point 1.1 update
the latest title update is preparing
siege for the arrival of loot boxes
called alpha packs the chance based loot
system will contain past and current
cosmetic items as well as legendary tier
items that will be exclusive to alpha
packs Ubisoft is staggering the release
of alpha packs across the ps4 Xbox one
and PC to ensure there's no hitches also
as part of this update the issues with
attacker hub on this explosive pellet
gun have been resolved after finding the
pellets would sometimes detonate early
among other issues the developer
completely rebuilt the backend systems
of the gadget so you should be good to
go elsewhere maps canal and coastline
have been tweaked after closing a
portion of the map to combat spawn
killing Erie sometimes reactive defense
feedback and reopen to the control room
with some extra cover while coastline
has had its malls completely rebuilt so
they should now destroy properly next up
let's talk about you getting some game
II type things on the cheap unless
you've been living under a rock you
probably noticed it's Amazon Prime day
unfortunately the deals aren't global so
if you're lucky enough to live in one of
the territories that they are happening
here's what you can get if you're an
Amazon Prime member in the US you can
grab the PlayStation slim 500 gigabyte
Uncharted full bundle a two hundred and
twenty nine bucks oh the Xbox one S 500
gigabyte bundled with packed in goodies
alike a wireless controller and three
digital games at two hundred and forty
bucks there are also a ton of game deals
that include the aforementioned Rainbow
six siege for $15 45 on ps4 go and get
it and final fantasy 15 on Xbox one for
26 bucks in the UK there is also a slew
of game and console deals including a
bundle with a 500 gigabyte ps4 slim
overwatch end crash bandicoot and sang
trilogy plus an extra Dual Shock
controller for 180 pounds for the full
list of deals for the US and UK check
out our stories on GameSpot finally and
when I say finally I want to point out
that I mean in conclusion in or finally
as in like something's finally happened
we have a story about halfway for you
that's right unfortunately it's not hot
three but the first half-life game has
been updated the first game I ever
played at a LAN party was updated today
to fix a number of crash scenarios
there's not really anything too exciting
other than a game released in 1998 being
patched and the patch notes acknowledge
the players who reported the bugs for
those of you interested or any
conspiracy theorists who want to see
half-life 3 teasers the patch notes
address things like crashes from
entering malformed strings into the game
console and no more crashes while
quickly changing consumable weapons or
when setting custom decals the half-life
expansions opposing force and blue shift
have also been updated but the full list
of everything that's changed head on
over the games but that is it from us
today do you let us know down in that
comment box which old games you still
like to play and we will see you guys
tomorrow